yeah another story i remember that you
told and their stories were great and
before i had ever seen your stand-up and
if you don't want to tell this you don't
have to tell it and if we tell it and
you want to cut it i'll cut it
but um
you were getting some heat at the
beginning of that show
and um you people were calling you from
all over and there was a um a benefit to
raise money oh yeah can i tell this
story yeah okay kirk douglas
kirk douglas is for those that don't
know
spartacus yeah michael douglas's father
well wait wait so but you didn't know
that you didn't know that then
no i didn't know anything you didn't
know anything about it so the it was the
uh pr uh unions uh benefit yeah
celebrating kirk douglas at the beverly
hills hotel this was you know um a few
years ago about eight nine years ago and
if you know anything about kirk douglas
besides playing spartacus and being an
academy award-winning actor and the
father of michael douglas he
he suffered uh 20 years before from a
stroke a horrible stroke which kind of
but they don't tell you that they don't
have no warning on that well and he
couldn't speak he lost his his ability
to uh speak clearly they also don't tell
you it's not even on the card it's the
whole function and there's like
so he gets on his answering machine theo
somebody saw you on tv and somebody saw
you in another show and they said you'd
be perfect for it you're really funny
you're witty we would love you to come
to the beverly hills hotel
and host
uh the kirk douglas benefit yeah and uh
theo doesn't you know he's busy
um yes well he did say yes but i don't
think he heard the word host he heard
roast
[Laughter]
he heard roast
this was serious and when when this was
happening i was with him he was
legitimately upset he goes to the hotel
and who are some of the people that are
there in the audience and
dang uh he said sally field was sally
field telefield was there and i didn't
know if it was sally field or fields and
he didn't know kirk douglas had a stroke
yeah well here's the thing they just you
know you think publicis guild they
[ __ ] give you some intel right so i
had nothing bro they sent me out there
and i thought it was a roast so we wrote
all these rose jokes me and my friend
matt weiss wrote the roast jokes
about
kirk douglas yeah
and
the man is like 95 years old he can't
speak didn't you call attention to that
in the roast how good an actor is he
can't even everything's a vowel
didn't you say that he doesn't have one
[ __ ] consonant
and then you get up to do the rose
listen to this guy
and what happened and then they said oh
he said uh
what did we say man we said
we said oh i his publicist job must be
easy um he's still alive that's just her
announcement every year
we ripped him he was 90 something years
old you know and so i thought it was a
roast for how for uh how old he was
whatever his name was harold douglas
so i get there dude and i've been out
the night before bro i wasn't even
really doing that great and so i get
over there wrote all these jokes
the craziest part was one joke there's
one guy that laughs right the lights are
off in there right one guy that laughs
and it's a black guy laughing right i
grew up in a black neighborhood i know a
black eye laugh from a white guy
laughing unless it's lester holt but
there was a guy in the room that was
laughing that you were sure was black
and it was right so there's a hole one
laugh goes it's one lap bro there's a
thousand people in there so when i
finally get allowed
and i said
and i think the joke in maybe ben had a
little wraith some racial undertone so
the one who laughs is black and i'm like
at least the brother laughed for me
right i said that right
so for some reason
they bring the lights up as if we need
to see if it's a black eyeliner oh my
god
the only thing that went right in the
whole production
is that at some point when i mentioned
that that's a black guy laughing they
bring the [ __ ] lights
and and it was
it was lester holt
the one black guy they invited to the
thing found enjoyed it
but didn't but didn't they come up and
stop you oh yeah they shut me down
didn't sally fields come up and stop you
and say sally feel was good who oh i
remember this was the craziest part
so it kept going bad
you know and nobody was telling me
nothing man you know and you're roasting
kirk oh i'm roasting everybody they had
a couple ah this is the worst part they
had a couple children from like siam or
something that came in with some
documentary
and i roasted those back
i just didn't know what was going on
but it was no rehearsal i didn't even
know what the [ __ ] this thing was
morphing children yeah
those stinging man and everybody's
eating out there eating salmon bro
and uh
and the worst part was i went backstage
robert downey jr is back there with um
[Music]
the guy i want to say corbin burns is
that a man yeah yeah it is a man and a
white man
it is yeah and a white man
so corbin bernsen and how uh and uh
robert downey jr
are standing backstage and this before
iron man this is when he had just i
think messed with the hookers or
something okay or the men whatever
happened i don't know who did it
i don't know what it was man
but when he got high and then he woke up
in somebody else's house yeah whatever
you want to call it okay
we've all got different version of gay
chickens we've all used robert downey jr
we all tell different elements of the
story but okay
but he was at oh uh he was oh wait he
was backstage oh wait maybe iron man had
just he started doing iron man okay all
right yeah because i'm thinking years
before i'd seen him at a party when i
first got to town and no and everybody
was like like you know our people were
saying mean stuff about him at the party
um but this was at the uh
hotel the wilshire motel
so i'm over there that's your motel or
wherever it was that publishes yields
beverly hills
the motel
whatever it was dude i don't know they
[ __ ] made me park far off
so the further i park the more motel it
gets
so anyway i'm backstage he's back there
oh this is what happened he goes
and they knew it was going bad
they knew it was going bad i mean you
know it's bad when iron man shows up
right
he's saving
and he goes hey man in 10 years nobody
will remember it
and and it's crazy because sick five
years older i'd seen him and in in at a
low point in his career or you know at
the media's low point in his career yeah
and so coming from him it was like a
nice thing to hear because here we go
that's a beautiful compliment
what year what did this happen ten years
ago
yeah that's why we're bringing it up
today
he goes 10 years from now nobody will
know that this nobody will know what's
happened oh wait [ __ ] we just screwed
ourselves
but i think that's a nice compliment
when things are going bad and there's
somebody back there to just give you
like oh him and the other guy it was the
only two people that knew that would
even talk to me what about the black guy
from the audience yeah he would i think
but he wanted to get out of there
because the lights were up and he was
yeah who knows what was going on with
him i don't know but it was that's one
of the funniest stories thank you they
set me up man
[Music]
you